hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 14 video the return
we also have details on next week's
episode nanda parbat and two new
characters so I'll try to explain all
that stuff just an update on the
schedule I know there's a lot of
question because the flash is going on
break for three weeks but next week is a
new episode of arrow episode 15 after
that it'll go on break too and then come
back with a flash ok so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet starting with top five moments
number five
Theon Oliver train on the island didn't
you notice how they were training with
the Escrima sticks just like Slade
taught Oliver to use them Marc
Guggenheim called the episode a love
letter to the fans so that's why they
called back to so many familiar moments
and locations on the island and in
Starling didn't you also notice how
there was a lot of explaining going on
in this episode it's like Oliver is
speaking for the audience when he asks
the how she got so good so fast
she's like Merlin's a good teacher did
he teach you how to cheat usually the
supporting characters the ones they give
funny lines to like that like Felicity
or Diggle it's like the show is telling
us in no uncertain terms that whenever
Thea is fighting
she's a main character like she's just
as good as Oliver probably probably not
true she's probably better with a sword
but not a better fighter overall
definitely more vicious though on to
number four flashback Oliver goes back
to Starling city
seeing team arrow and flashback was so
much fun like Felicity almost brushes
past him when he's stealing the data
Thea doing as many drugs as she can get
her hands on Laurel is a little bit more
pessimistic it looks like her romance
with Tommy hadn't started yet
Tommy has actually taken on the Oliver
role and is being like the big brother
to everyone and Quentin is an off the
rails drunk that bar that Laurel walked
into and in phantomon that's actually
the same bar that he first met Sara and
whenever she first came back to Starling
there were so many familiar locations
like China white using the foundry to
conduct her illegal sale I think part of
the reasons why they visited all these
familiar locations is because they
already built those sets and it's
cheaper for them to reuse sets than it
is to build new ones and in doing so
they're able to honor really big moments
from the past in the show it's just
funny to think from a production
standpoint but it's like you have this
big love letter to the fandom but it
allows you to reuse a bunch of sets so
you save a bunch of money high five to
showrunner Marc Guggenheim in the
production designer on to number three
Merlin wants Oliver to regain his killer
edge they buried the lead on this a
little bit because they didn't end up
killing Slade at the end
and said Argos was looking for a
volunteer guard for the island that
means that Merlin flew all the way to
the island worked as a volunteer guard
long enough to set up slaves escape or
at least time it so that he escaped
about the time Oliver and Thea were
arriving a lot of you guys have asked me
in the last couple weeks if I think that
Oliver's gonna start killing people
again obviously this this kind of
sidesteps the issue I kind of expected
that's what they would do they would
find a way for Oliver to not throw his
morals away really the journey that
Oliver's on this season is getting to
that balance point where he can be both
Oliver Queen and the arrow cuz right now
he's like I can only be the arrow Oliver
Queen can't exist I can't I can't be a
normal person that's how the whole mess
with Felicity started be on the other
hand as slate implies is lost to him
obviously that's that's not true she's
totally gonna come back at some point
she'll find that balance to the end
Merlyn had that moment at the end where
she's like I'm gonna do whatever you say
but you're dead to me I'll never be your
daughter again one of my earlier
theories is is that Merlyn is going to
have to sacrifice his life in order to
win back Thea's affection going through
that experience might be a way to bring
Thea back from that darkness to that's
just like an early finale prediction
that could always change depending on
how the back half of the season goes
there's still a ton of episodes to come
Mar Guggenheim said it's gonna get way
crazier but speaking of killer edge
probably my favorite flashback moment
was when Oliver killed that drug dealer
like he didn't even hesitate just crunch
through him over the balcony it's the
easiest way to show how things have
changed so much in that time span it's
like the Star Trek mirror universe in
the flashbacks everybody has a lot more
facial hair they're like evil versions
of themselves they kill people they get
really dark they're drunk
speaking of which we finally see
diggle's brother I can't remember if
we've ever seen diggle's brother before
some somebody can let me know in the
comments I don't remember the last time
we saw him there are so many flashback
moments that I could talk about I'm
gonna actually put some of them in my
Easter eggs in just a sec onca number
two Oliver watches his father's secret
message so when he almost gets caught by
Felicity he finds the message for Thea
for Oliver I bet you we're gonna see the
feel one pretty soon
his father died on the island so he's
kind of already gone through the
grieving process it's been a while since
he died this message is just like the
next step in learning about the list and
his first year as the vigilante I failed
this city but you can save
that's probably the best Easter Egg for
where the phrase you failed the city
came from don't you just wonder though
what is in Thea's message does it have
something to do with Merlin being her
father
if Moira was smart enough to figure out
that Oliver had been the arrow the whole
time then all of his father totally knew
Thea's secret if you remember back to
season 2 where they had that rift where
Thea's like I don't feel like part of
this family Oliver says he might not
have been your biological father but he
was your father he's your family the
secret message will probably repair that
relationship a little bit Thea will
slowly come back to the fold but she'll
become like the speedy character
it'll be speedy Thea a lot of you have
been asking me which comic book
character I think that Thea's gonna be
they actually DC Comics posted a picture
of speedy so she's gonna be like the
speedy from the comics her backstory
kind of works with that with the drug
abuse but we can talk about that as her
character develops across the back half
of the season and my number one moment
general Matthew Shrieve introduces
creature commandos to arrow so if you
didn't recognize them at the end of the
episode that's mark singer he's mostly
known as being the Beastmaster but he
but he's at a much other stuff he is
playing general Matthew Shrieve who's a
character from the comics who led the
creature commandos they're like another
version of the Suicide Squad only with
all metahumans in the comics they're
actually led by Frankenstein so I'm not
expecting Frankenstein to come on arrow
anytime soon they're gonna be a big arc
in the back half of the season so that's
where the Hong Kong flashbacks scenes
are gonna be going they'll still be
going after China white in the bio
weapon but now it'll be this team based
stuff going on I don't think they'll
directly do creature commandos they
probably won't call it that they'll
adapt it they'll change a little bit
here's my big question for you guys what
was your favorite moment from the
episode and what do you think that
Merlyn is going to have to do to repair
his relationship with Thea remember he
said family is the most important thing
so he's gonna do whatever it takes to
keep his family quote-unquote together
here's a bunch of the Easter eggs that I
found in the flashbacks and in the
present-day Lian Yu scenes so one the
opening scene with Oliver and Thea
training with those screaming sticks
just like the scene where Oliver was
training with Slade but Slade taught
Oliver to use the sticks so Oliver
trains Thea to use the sticks in an
episode where they're back on the island
the Deathstroke is also in Oliver tells
Thea I've been back here before he's
talking about the island obviously when
we see him in episode 1 in the pilot
episode he has the mega
leeadams beard that's after all the
flashbacks are over so between where we
are right now in the flashbacks in
present-day he's already come and gone
from the island a couple times right now
Stephen Amell said they're about halfway
through the flashback so for every one
year in present-day they only move about
a half a year in the flashbacks
whenever Quentin comes to the party to
investigate the dead drug dealer that
Oliver killed his former captain says
maybe there's a mystery vigilante going
around town
Oliver is also wearing a green hoodie
that looks exactly like Roy's old red
hoodie Masayo goes on to say that that's
fooling no one
anybody could recognize you and that
even if you smear your face in grease
paint which is what he does in
present-day all the time that's why
whenever you see Stephen Amell do his
Q&A sometimes he has those really
blacked-out eyes sockets that's the
grease paint that he puts on when Thea
and Oliver are fighting Slade off
there's this moment where he twists him
around it looks just like the scene from
the flare Oh crossover from flash versus
arrow when Oliver is yanking the arrow
out of Barry's back China white uses the
foundry to conduct her secret
clandestine Armageddon sale then later
she says you make the call the
Yamashiro's died tonight that actually
that might be leading up to Masayo son
dying that's what that's why I think
they had that falling-out him and katana
it seems like they hadn't been speaking
in present day obviously something
tragic happened probably their son dying
we meet mark singer as general Matthew
Shrieve Fabio obviously already
explained the creature commandos from
the comics he's a lot of fun so get
really excited about that and then
really important thing Oliver tells Thea
not to tell Laurel about any of the Sara
murder stuff it will unnecessarily
complicate things which is a total red
herring of course she's gonna find out
it's gonna cause complete chaos in the
group it's like the rules of a horror
movie
anytime you say something you don't want
to happen it's guaranteed to happen if
you haven't seen it yet they posted the
teaser for episode 15 Nanda Parbat
obviously going to Nanda Parbat but in
back in Starling we're gonna see the
atom suit for the first time he's quite
to face justice
welcome to Nanda Papa you spent years
preparing to bring a bow and arrow to a
sword fight
I know some of you guys don't like
spoilers so so I won't explain episode
15 too much but it's pretty
straightforward team arrow goes to Nanda
Parbat everyone that's involved with the
Ray Palmer storyline mostly Felicity
stays in Starling and gets involved in
an atom storyline they also just
announce they cast a new character Doug
Jones from Hellboy Fame he's got a whole
bunch of creature work he's going to be
playing a character in episode 19 called
death bolt he will be a metahuman is a
character from the comics he has plasma
discharge powers it sounds like he's
going to be a metahuman in the episode
but they haven't explained if he's going
to be a metahuman that got his powers
from the STAR Labs accident or if he got
his powers some other way the name of
that episode episode 19 is Broken Arrow
if you've never heard it before the term
Broken Arrow is a military term it
refers to a nuclear weapon being lost so
so when you're Theory crafting about
episode 19 stuff just think about it
that way something major like a major
weapon gets lost what major weapons have
we been seeing in the flashbacks what
major weapon do we have in the present
actually in the president might not
refer to a physical weapon it might
refer to a person as in the era so maybe
Oliver is going to be broken somehow so
I will be doing a Q&A tomorrow be sure
to subscribe to get that I'm also
wearing my like Stephen Amell sin
seriously t-shirt he's asking people to
send them sin series video so I might
make us in serious video too
why do you guys wait for that stuff to
drop you can click here to catch up on
the flash this week and you can click
here to catch up on Gotham thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives
you